today is the Democratic strategist Jamal
Simmons worked for President Bill
Clinton and advised President Barack
Obama's 2008 campaign he's a CBS News
political contributor and he also works
for hill TV and he joins us now Jamal
good morning good morning folks so this
is a very peculiar trial unfolding in
the Senate you have lawyers for the
president trying to rebut the evidence
that's been brought forth so far and at
the very same time kind of in the wings
just off stage more evidence seems to be
percolating and keep in mind you call it
a trial these guys sitting in the Senate
and women we're sitting in the Senate
are judges as well as jurors as well as
litigants because they get to actually
ask questions and and request more
information so I think what we're
looking for is almost like church right
we've got three senators is there one
more no but Jake's is coming here is
there one more and I think the Democrats
are trying to put pressure on some of
these folks who might be statesman or
state's women to say listen the country
is at stake here you guys should come
out you'll be able to find the one more
and what are the risk for the one more
coming forward so I think that they are
maybe one or two more the question
though is when do they come out and they
might wait to come out into the very
last minute why Donald Trump will go ham
on anybody who is trying to yeah very
hard the Republican strategy is to
attack Bolton's credibility yes is it an
effective strategy yes because they
attack everybody's credibility the
question now will be bolted as one of
theirs right Bolton is a tried and true
Republican tried and true conservative
yeah I think they've got a lot of
internal politics they're gonna have to
manage Donald Trump seems to say forget
about the rest of the Republican
politics I'm the only Republican that
matters are you with me are you against
something else Republicans say is hey
look this impeachment trial is getting
ahead of an election that's coming up so
let's talk about Iowa because that's
where a lot of Democrats are campaigning
right now who do you think is emerging
right now as as a leader in Iowa and
where does that take the race going
forward it's clear Bernie Sanders is the
one on the ascent you know we look and
talk at all about top a lot about the
Senators who are sitting in Washington
and can't campaign in Iowa Bernie
Sanders is the one who's got the most
devoted following
so his people they don't move they're
gonna stick and stay with them the other
people are still in the persuasion
business
Elizabeth Warren
and the others are trying to get people
to come to them the Bernie Sanders's
already persuaded his voters you know if
he's pulling a 25% that still means
three out of four people say not him
sure but when you got eight or nine
people in the ballot that could matter
but right now they are calling it a
surge why do you think he's surging at
this particular time I think people are
looking for we've seen this in a lot of
polling and I'm just gonna say it here
on television a lot of people are
looking for an old white guy to fight
the president right okay so that's why
you see Biden and you see Bernie being
very strong and all the polling and you
see something more remarkable a lot of
people who like Biden say they'll go to
Bernie even though they're idiot
logically very different people
except there's got what we were talking
in the green room about another old
white guy who people are starting to
talk about which is Bloomberg what are
you seeing percolating there little
Brook is making a lot of moves he spent
obviously spending 200 million dollars
in digital ads and that matters in an
election it was a such confined time
space he's campaigning in places where
other voters aren't they're not in
California they're not in Michigan my
dad is in Michigan I've been talking
about people going to Bloomberg meetings
and how people are starting to show up
just to ask questions and see if it's
real a month ago I would have said no
way a billionaire with criminal justice
problems is going to be the nominee of
the Democratic Party today I'd say let's
be a little bit more patient and take a
look at your dad is not an old white guy
with you know he is saying that blue
Brooks interesting I mean he's been all
over the map he's not somebody who's for
any particular person my mom however
loves Amy Klobuchar right but there are
a lot of Democrats who are a particular
person yeah and I was just in Iowa last
weekend I heard from a lot of people
said Bernie Sanders he may be leading in
the polls but you know socialist is not
a word we like around here that's right
you know Republicans will tar him with
that absolutely one more thing before we
go
those five impeachment managers were up
there they're all up there for a reason
I think you're gonna see them be
superstars on a democratic stage going
for the rest of the year there'll be
surrogates for every congressional
campaign whoever the presidential
nominee is what's happening in the
Senate right absolutely this is the
first stage of the Democratic argument
about why Donald Trump should be
President again jamal simmons thank you
very much